painful day coming back to a place that
i
love and respect so much albeit
virtually
um but in these circumstances and i've
had plenty of time to reflect on
what has happened i welcome this inquiry
and its related reviews
and i believe they're important lessons
to be learned
it was the greatest honour of my life to
be prime minister
of this country and when my services
prime minister came to an end
i wanted to build a new career based on
a mix of charitable
and pro bono work for causes that i care
about
like dementia and international
development and business interests in
areas of cutting-edge technology
i believe that an ex-prime minister
should be able to do that and i thought
carefully about the choices i made and
took extensive advice
as part of that range of activity i
would explain why i chose to work for
greensville capital
the circumstances under which i
contacted government ministers and
others
and my motivations for doing so i'll
also explain how abided
by the rules that were in place
but rules alone are never enough we
learned that in this place over so many
issues
personal conduct and codes of behavior
and how such conduct
and behavior both appears and can be
perceived
these things matter too i completely
accept that
former prime ministers are in a
different position to others because of
the office that we held
and the influence that continues to
bring we need to think differently
and act differently lobbying itself is a
necessary and healthy part of our
democratic process
but i accept there's a strong argument
that having a former prime minister
engage on behalf of any commercial
interest no matter how laudable the
motives and cause
can be open to misinterpretation perhaps
that's especially so when the
communication systems we all use
particularly in the heat of responding
to a crisis our text phone and app
rather than the more formal approach of
writing
i hope it is accepted that nothing i did
was in breach of the rules
but on the wider test of what is
appropriate as i've said previously
it would be better only to use the most
formal means of contact
via a letter i started working as a
senior advisor to green cell capital in
august 2018.
lex greenseal wanted me to help him grow
what was becoming a successful uk-based
fintech firm there was geopolitical and
strategic advice
helping with international expansion
speaking at customer and supplier events
and helping to win new customers i like
the fact that the business was using
technology
and deep capital markets to help small
businesses and supply chains
to get low cost credit to get paid early
i had seen how this had worked in
government when lex greensall was
brought in
by jeremy hayward to advise my
administration from 2011
though at the time as i've explained i
only met him very briefly
this was all part of the civil service
drive to improve government efficiency
in bringing him in jeremy was acting in
good faith
to solve a real problem how to ensure
companies and supply
chains particularly smes could access
low-cost credit
in terms of my role i was not employed
at green sill as a lobbyist
and lobbying the uk government was never
intended to be part of my role
however in the economic turmoil caused
by kovid the government quite rightly
introduced
several schemes to help ensure that
credit would continue to be expanded
expanded to business
the green cell proposal was to make this
even more effective
and i believe that it should be
considered by government this was
particularly the case as what was being
suggested
was very similar to action that had been
taken during the financial crisis in
2008
in which businesses like green silk have
been involved
my motivation for contacting ministers
and others was to help uk firms at this
moment of difficulty
and to ensure that fintech firms and
greenson in particular
were listened to as well as the major
clearing banks
my reason for contacting the chancellor
and others so directly
was because these solutions were being
considered introduced and amended
in rapid time and i believe green silk
could help the country
at this time of acute health and
financial crisis
i knew that any meetings between
greensville and officials that were
being asked for
would quite rightly be publicly reported
not least because of the rules on
transparency that i helped to put in
place as prime minister
greenster was not asking for direct
government support
or some sort of bailout and at this
stage april last year
i certainly had no sense at all that the
business itself
was in any danger of collapse separately
in 2019
greensled decided to extend the idea of
paying suppliers early
to businesses most important supplier of
all its workforce
i thought this was a very appealing idea
allowing employees to draw down their
salary as they earned it
for free rather than having to wait till
the end of the month
seemed an effective way amongst other
things to help
end the scourge of payday lending for
firms in the private sector
while there'd be a charge for the
employer there would never be a charge
for the employee
and in the public sector it would be
free for both employer
and employee i became an enthusiastic
supporter of this new app
earned it was called and wanted to
promote it to the nhs and other public
sector bodies
i could see a profound social benefit
from the take up
of this technology i'm desperately sorry
that green silk and earned
went into administration hundreds of
hard-working people
have lost their jobs and many more are
threatened by the consequences
as i was neither a director of the
company nor involved in any lending
decisions by the company
i have no special insight into what
ultimately happened
but i'm as keen as anyone to learn the
lessons and hope that these inquiries
will help with that process
i know you're also examining the rules
governing lip lobbying and business
appointments
after ministers and officials leave
office and any special arrangements for
former prime ministers
and on that subject i have these brief
thoughts
the lobbying rules were put in place to
deal with lobbying by multi-client firms
rather than employees of individual
businesses to ensure that those being
orbit
knew on whose behalf they were being
contacted this was of course backed by
the fact
that the the existence of all relevant
and subsequent meetings
with businesses are then made public if
lobbying registration can be extended to
in-house operatives without excessive
bureaucracy
or damaging the interests of charities
there is a case for making that change
the body that vets jobs
for former ministers and civil servants
acaba
is well established and in my view works
but its examination of appointments
should be mandatory
and comprehensive and its decisions
should be enforceable
as i said at the outset former prime
ministers are in a different category
and i've read the arguments for
different special arrangements
a longer period before any contact with
government over
any commercial issue could be
appropriate
and a new special committee over and
above acaba
to advise on post office appointments
might help with choices that need to be
made
can i thank you chair for letting me
make that opening statement
okay thank you david for that that did
run over what we had agreed in terms of
time i had to say
and i think it's therefore i wasn't
intending traces but i will as a
consequence of that
um we were allocated rather less time
than we had asked
uh your office for uh for this session
so that we could complete
our scrutiny effectively so i feel bound
to ask you now in the event that we
don't
get through this session having fully
scrutinized all the areas with you that
we
uh we require to could i have a
commitment from you now that you will
return to this committee
to answer any subsequent questions we
may have well of course we've got i
think
two hours and i'm very happy to start
running the clock from now so uh if that
helps i'm certainly happy to do that
yes it was in the event that we don't
get through everything we had over three
hours in fact that would be an hour less
i think
on average compared to the other
sessions we've had including with lex
green saw himself
so could i have a commitment that in the
event that we don't get through
everything today you will come back and
appear before us
again very happy to answer all the
questions good
okay well you um sorry just i'm very
clear when you say happy to answer all
the questions that is a yes to coming
back to the committee if we
request it well let's see how we get on
i'm sure we've got till
effectively till five o'clock but uh if
we haven't got through them then of
course um
we think we can do this again you see i
think the committee would um
justifiably expect a straight answer to
that question as to whether
i've said if we don't get through it
then i'm very happy to come back again
okay well
if i take that therefore unless you're
going to contradict me that if we don't
get through it
to the satisfaction of the committee and
we therefore
invite you back that you will come back
and answer our further questions
thank you very much thank you now you
mentioned in your statement david that
you were not a director of greensboro
which of course is true
but let's sprinkle when he gave his
evidence to us this week
uh stated that you had an open
invitation to board meetings
and that you attended uh regularly is
that
the case yes okay thank you
during the run-up to the uh pandemic and
the pandemic itself
did you take part in discussions on the
board
uh of grenzill or were you there simply
as an observer
well i was there um invited to attend
the board
um but i would take part in the board
meetings and
listen to the arguments and make
contributions sometimes particularly on
sort of
geopolitical matters and such like so
yes i was a regular attender
and would contribute but of course there
are a lot of board issues which are
director only i didn't sit on the credit
committee i didn't sit on the risk
committee
didn't sit on the audit committee or any
of those sorts of functions
so i wasn't involved as it were in the
day-to-day
uh running of the business or credit
decisions
but yes of course i'd listen to the
discussions and and make contributions
and did those discussions at the time
that the pandemic emerged
include the difficulties that
green salt may in the future face as a
consequence of the pandemic
i don't recall a particulars of course
the pandemic hit
very quickly i'd have to go back and
check
um exactly when the board meetings were
but
uh i did have discussions with um lex
greensell
himself about you know what effectively
was a sort of
you know mini economic heart attack um
as the covid uh situation hit
and you know we are in a situation where
no one knew how
high unemployment would go how badly
growth would be affected exactly what
would happen to credit markets i mean it
was
going back to that time an extraordinary
economic period and so of course we were
discussing those things
would so would you have discussed the
future potential threat that the
pandemic posed in terms of the
profession
the availability for example of credit
insurance going forward
an increased risk of uh the clients of
the company
defaulting and the pressure on continued
access to funding through the
securitization process within the model
that
green sill was uh was working to i don't
recall
particular discussions on the insurance
issue there were
discussions obviously about the state of
the credit markets and the access to
credit markets and the concern there was
that
the companies in supply chains that we
helped to finance
you know may may struggle in in those
markets and it was very important
to keep those markets open um so yes
there was that discussion and of course
i sure would come on to this the
remarks of the governor of the bank of
england that supply chains were
important and the effect of the
pandemic on supply chains was something
that needed to be looked at
and did you recognize that the extent
that the pandemic would
impose pressure uh on the insurance
market and therefore by extension the
ability of
tokai marine and others to provide
insurance
uh to the uh green salt business that
that was
a potential major problem coming down
the track that you should
have been able to foresee i i don't
recall that
particular conversation as i say i mean
the the main focus of my
i'll have to go back and check exactly
when the board meetings were and
and whether i was in attendance but the
discussions i remember
as covid hit and as the economic
problems started the discussions were
about the state of the
credit markets um and
the impact that might have on
particularly businesses not being able
to access
credit and uh that was really the the
discussion that that we were having
um and then that obviously turned into
this issue of what could we do to
to try and help at that stage but i'm
thinking more about green sill in its
position at the moment so back at the
time when the lobby
is happening now when i say i don't
recall any particular conversations
about the insurance issue
um i obviously might in terms of my
conversations about
green sill um grinsel was in good
financial health
we had had the soft bank investment into
the company which should put
a billion dollars effectively into the
company
greensville had a successful 2019 it
looks set to have a successful
2020 obviously kovid was going to have
its
impact but at no stage um
in those conversations was was i aware
in any way of any concern um that you
know green sill would be in any serious
financial difficulty this might be a
tougher year than the one before uh no
one could quite tell what was around the
corner but there was a certainly no
sense of jeopardy
uh if that's what you're asking whilst
they're there a sense that
um with the pandemic the appetite within
the insurance sector for taking risk
would be diminished i mean i think
that's a well understood concept and
therefore
there might have been some possibility
that it would be much more difficult for
green sill to secure that insurance
cover
which after all totally underpinned the
model that it was running as i say
the conversations i remember i i would
have to go back to the board meeting the
conversations i remember were more about
the state of the credit markets
um and the ability there would be uh as
as people were talking i remember this
this period the whole conversation um
in government and finance was um what
can we do to make sure that
banks keep lending what can make sure to
do to credit markets
to stay open for businesses to access
access credit i don't remember
particular
conversations about the insurance
situation but as i say
um i'm not on the credit and risk
committees and so there may have been
conversations going on
um elsewhere but that wasn't
particularly the conversation i was
having
at that time can i ask you a a delicate
question but i think a very important
one because you have spoken in your
opening statement about the motivations
that you had for
the lobbying et cetera helping smes and
so on um
what was the arrangement in broad terms
in terms of your personal arrangement
with the business i i believe you may
have had some share options etc
there's been all sorts of speculation in
the press some people saying that you've
suggested to friends you could
if everything went the right way uh make
a gain of about 60 million pounds others
have said that's a vastly inflated
figure
um can you tell us something about what
you would expect to have gained
had the uh your involvement gone to plan
and you'd had an effective exit from the
business at some point in the future
well i was paid a annual amount a
generous annual amount far more than
what i earned as prime minister
and i had shares not share options but
shares in the business which vested over
the period of
time of my contract
and so it's like it's important for the
committee to know that i
you know was absolutely had a big
economic investment in the future
of green cell i wanted the business to
succeed i wanted it to grow
i haven't put a number on those things
because while i think it's very
important in the questions
you're asking you know what was my role
how did i carry it out
was it appropriate to lobby uh did i
overstep the mark
um you know brought the broader
questions of what ex-prime ministers
should and shouldn't do
the fact that i had this economic
interest and a serious economic interest
that's important but i don't
think the amount is particularly germane
to answering those questions and as
far as i'm concerned it's a private
matter
well well it is it isn't though is it
because um
if the incentive was a matter of some
tens of thousands of pounds that would
be distinctly different than if it was
multiple millions of pounds i think
in terms of the potential motivation you
therefore
uh had for for the the lobbying that was
carried out i mean you must accept that
i mean
do you view the 60 million pound figure
as just totally absurd or are we talking
about that
it's a completely absurd figure but i
can tell you the motivation for
contacting the government was that i
thought we had a
really good idea for how to help
how to help extending credit to
thousands of businesses and i'd quite
like to explain why i thought it was
you know yeah well such a great idea
because i think you know
and i've sat on the other side of the
fence um
in government where you have a credit
crunch you have difficulties in the
credit market
and you're desperate to get banks
lending and you're desperate to get
credit to businesses and i
well remember standing at the dispatch
box
and you know being asked will this
scheme that you announced six months ago
how many companies are taking part how
many banks are taking part and often
having to give very disappointing
answers so i was
very keen for us to put forward our
scheme because i thought it was
absolutely in the public interest to try
and get
money into into small businesses okay
that's fine but
my questions and they are as i say
delicate questions but i think they're
an important question because if there
is a
large amount of money riding on this
business succeeding and that is a
different situation for a small amount
of
money riding on the business succeeding
and i i think i take it from what you're
saying that
there was at least a significant amount
i had a significant i wanted this
business to succeed i was being paid i
had shares i had a
interest in it and and i think that's
important for the committee to know and
of course
you know just as if a bank
takes part in a loan guarantee scheme
that's good for the country because
those loan guarantees will go to
businesses so green sale if our scheme
have been
accepted of being able to use supply
chain finance bonds to get
cash into businesses up and down the
country that would have been good for
those businesses but also
i'm good for us and i wouldn't hide that
for a second but as i say the motivation
having been on the other side of the
fence knowing when you're looking for
these solutions
that it's so difficult sometimes to make
them work the motivation was about
trying to help the government
to get those schemes right made that
point and we're clear on that thank you
so
in your written evidence to us uh you
said
quote you became concerned that the
company might be in serious financial
difficulty in december 2020 now that's
not quite the same as
uh for example at the time the lobbying
believing that there were looming issues
coming down
the track and there seems to be quite a
lot of evidence out there that
you might have come to that conclusion
that whilst you're right the
the company wasn't about to fall over at
the start of the pandemic when the
lobbying happened nonetheless
it was going into some fairly choppy
waters now let's play
the green cell in his evidence to us
said that at the time of the lobbying
quote we did not know what was going to
happen next
uh he said that the ccff access was a
liquidity insurance
uh policy he went on to say that this
was a prudent
thing for us to do in other words to try
and get access to ccff he also told us
it's important also if i can remind the
committee that for the credit insurance
market covid was an extraordinarily
frightening time
when there was an expectation of very
very significant losses
now given the centrality of the
availability of insurance to the model
indeed when it was removed
the whole business collapsed that's
quite a powerful thing to say and he was
saying that in relation to the period
that the lobbying was occurring we had
press reports
uh throughout the run-up to uh the
pandemic enduring in it
uh for example on the fourth of may 2020
which was during the period of the
lobbying
there were the ft reported that my quote
brings hill had suffered
a raft of client defaults
we had parliamentary questions from lord
miners asking the government to
investigate various aspects of
uh green sales business that goes back
to june 2019 well before
the uh lobbying uh occurred uh
we had uh an email from lex greensell to
charles roxburg at the bank of england
21st of march during the period of the
lobby
in which he says quote with capital
markets close to us we may need to
reduce the credit we can deliver
in the coming week should the ccff
not be open to us and your email to sir
john cunliffe for the bank of england
were 22nd people so once again during
the
as part of the lobbying you told him
quote while some parts of the capital
markets are operating well for green
seal
capacity remains severely constrained
and the fca in its response to my letter
to them
said i quote in early 2020 and
particularly after the onset of the
pandemic in march there was widespread
distress
in financial markets across financial
services firms and other sectors of the
economy it was reported at various times
in the media
that green seal may be one of many such
films facing defaults
fca staff were aware of these reports
yet you're
saying or seem to be saying that at the
time of the lobbying you did not believe
that there was a significant
looming threat to the business and of
course for green cell
as a business heading into difficult
waters access to ccff would have helped
greensville's clients and so help green
sill
itself so i have to put a difficult
question
to you uh david and i i think it's right
uh that i do so that many people would
conclude that at the time of your logins
your opportunity to make a large amount
of money
was under threat not least because of
the pandemic
and its likely future impact on the
insurance arrangements that held the
whole business together
and that you surely must have known that
and that your fear of losing out on
those substantial gains motivated you to
conduct this barrage of tags
whatsapps emails meetings over 60
contacts in total
towards government ministers and civil
servants what do you have to say to
those
who hold that view that's not what i
felt at the time and it's not what
motivated me i think there's a huge
difference between
constrained capacity in the credit
markets and the risk of a business
failing and i think when
lex greensaul was in front of you he
also said that he didn't believe there
was a danger of the business
failing at that time he didn't think the
business faced failure until
as i did in december 2020
and if you look at what went on and
happened in the rest of that year
the business actually had quite a
successful year extending a similar
amount of credit in 2020 to what it did
in
2019 on the issue of defaults
like any financial institution you have
clients that
um do occasionally default but the
insurance effectively
covered that as far as i understand and
he gave the example
of nmc that did fail
for all sorts of reasons but green seal
was able to recover
the money for its clients because of the
insurance situation but i can
absolutely say to you that you know i
really believed
in the solution that we had and we were
putting to government that i thought
would
make a difference and that was my
motivation for doing so i mean i
spent most of my adult life in public
service i believe in it deeply
i would never put forward something that
i didn't think was
absolutely in the interests of the
public good and that's what i thought
i was doing on greenself's behalf we'll
come on to
i'm sure we can deal with in detail the
fact that there was
you know quite a lot of contact and
there was quite a lot of persistence and
i can explain
why there are very good reasons for that
um and i think it's important we
we cover that but just to be absolutely
clear i did not believe
in march or april uh when i was doing
this contact that there was a risk of
green seal falling over i didn't think
that and i think if you
look at what happened later on in that
year when green sill was
looking at a very successful capital
raise a lot of people wanted to invest
in the business
i mean just take the example of furlough
if this was a business in trouble
presumably it would have been
furloughing its staff i think it has a
thousand employees and
it didn't even access furlough until
december 2020 when i think it
followed six people in the property
department so
of course it's absolutely right to ask
these questions
but i am 100 clear that my motivation
for contacting the government is i
thought we had good ideas to help with
the credit crisis
and i could see as i said in my
statement the government
actually i think did an amazingly good
job at introducing schemes that really
did work
but at the time in march and april there
was this sense of schemes being
introduced and not working quite
properly and then being amended
and then being reintroduced because i
mean i know what it's like you're
looking for things that are going to
work
yeah okay all right let's go in the
furlough schemes of what we're going
to do um can i just move on to the
treasury very briefly and then i'm going
to pass on to another committee member
um part of our remit in this inquiry is
to
satisfy ourselves treasury uh responded
to your
lobbying uh appropriately um you would
i think accept that you would have uh
received
additional sort of a consideration shall
i put it this way from the cr
the treasury and the bank of england by
virtue of who you are
um can you kind of quantify qualify that
extra influence that you think you would
have had given that you're a former
prime minister
well i think i mean first of all i would
point you to the evidence that
tom scholar and charles roxbury gave to
the pac not yet to your committee where
you know they effectively said they
thought it was perfectly appropriate
that they were contacted
they didn't feel under any special
pressure they thought this was
area of business supply chain finance
that should be looked at
they thought they could be married if
the right scheme could be come up with i
think those are all
important considerations but i would
make this point and this
is sort of one of the reasons i thought
it was appropriate in these
extraordinary times when we were
suffering this
economic heart attack in the country to
pick up the phone
which is i knew from my time in
government that quite rightly when there
are
economic difficulties you know the
treasury is in contact with
every clearing bank the clearing bank
chairman and chief executives are
calling up quite rightly talking to the
treasury
and i thought it was important that
supply chain finance and fintechs who
are these days extending a lot of credit
to small businesses
also were able to put their points and i
think it is a
industry that's less well understood
that has less contact
and so i think it was important as well
as talking to the banks completely right
um that this uh conversation took place
as well and that's why
one of the reasons i think the treasury
officials have concluded that there
wasn't sort of
improper pressure do you feel that your
involvement
a led the treasury to open its door to
having conversations
uh more readily than it would otherwise
have done and b uh that having opened
the door that it
got involved in those compensated
conversations and the different
iterations of your ideas around ccff for
example
to a greater degree than had you not
been involved
well i'm sure of course you know your
position makes um a difference but i
think that
if you're the chancellor of the
exchequer you are also taking calls from
the heads and i remember this from
our timing government that you're taking
calls from the heads of
banks and building societies and they
are getting a very
and quite rightly i mean at a time of
crisis and this was the reason for
picking up the telephone rather than as
i've said i think would be better in
future
sending one sort of formal letter or
email is that
it was a time of crisis things were
moving very quickly the government was
introducing
schemes and plans and i think there's a
you know so
the persistence i would explain by first
of all
supply chain finance isn't so well
understood it did need a push to be
properly
um considered and then as you say it
went through a series of iterations of a
proposal by
green seal a response by the government
then the government making clear its own
scheme and then
and i think to be fair and i'll be very
frank about this i think greensell made
a mistake
and i'm partly responsible for this is i
don't think we got
to the best possible answer for how to
amend the ccff or include supply chain
finance in the ccff
nearly quickly enough and had we done
that there would have been
less calls less contact perhaps a
quarter as much and
i think we got that wrong but i mean i i
would
lean quite heavily in what the treasury
officials have said which is
this was effectively a worthwhile
conversation an important thing to talk
about
it didn't bend the treasury or the bank
of england out of shape
and i think was a useful process okay
thank you david thank you for those
answers i'm going to go now to harriet
please
thank you chair and um i wanted to just
uh reiterate what the chair said that
our terms of reference are really
looking at the lessons that uh
the treasury and its associated public
bodies can
uh derive from uh this whole failure of
green cell and so in that context i
wanted to
ask uh questions about the civil service
and my first question really and you've
mentioned him already
is tom scholar you obviously know him
very well can you tell us a little bit
about your relationship with tom scholar
well tom scholar and i worked together
when i was prime minister he was
um my the sort of number 10 sherpa for
the
g20 and g7 meetings
and also helping with the preparations
for european council meetings
i mean he's an extraordinarily able
civil servant i think we're very lucky
to have him he's now
permanent secretary to the treasury
and i think has done a very good job
during this pandemic
and um you signed up one of your texts
to him you know love dc
um which was the only one that you
signed off sort of love dc
um can you just help the committee
understand
you know in particular why you use that
to him
or you you have a closer or a wider
personal relationship outside
um the former one that you've just just
described i don't
i think i've seen him perhaps once or
twice since since leaving office i mean
anyone i
know even at all well i tend to sign off
text messages with love dc i
don't know why i just do but um my
children tell me that
you don't need to sign off text messages
at all and it's very old-fashioned and
odd to do so but
um anyway that's what i do so
i'm given that the treasury's guidance
to civil servants
um says that they need to be
particularly careful about conflicts of
interest with people with whom they have
a
personal relationship you would not
describe your relationship with tom
scholar as a personal relationship
no i as i say i've seen him once or
twice since leaving office in a in a
social context
for a drink or such like to talk about
things we did together but i would make
this point which is
it goes to these transparency rules
which i think are incredibly important
which is
obviously if anyone contacts an official
from business or elsewhere they're meant
to report that and they all
obviously did that in totally the proper
way but crucially what
i was doing on behalf of green seal was
saying will you look at this proposal
and will you talk to this company in the
full knowledge
that any meeting that was subsequently
held would be transparently reported so
the idea there was anything sort of
behind the hand or
or you know surreptitious trying to be
attempted
is nonsense these meetings are
transparently reported they weren't
before 2010
you could use a freedom of information
request to try and find out
which businesses ministers have been
meeting with but because of the reforms
i introduced in 2010
there's courtly reporting you see
exactly who's been meeting
who and i think that's very important
and i obviously knew that at the time
and knew that
uh if these meetings took place which i
hope they would
they'd be publicly reported on but so
you you don't have a relationship with
tom scholar where he comes to your house
for lunch or you know sunday lunch or
you know but something that wouldn't be
uh captured by the rules that you've
described it's it's not what you would
call a personal relationship is strictly
based on the you know it's now for
nearly five years since you were prime
minister but the contacts that you had
at the time correct yeah um
so you've not had lunch with him since
you've been prime minister then
uh i think i had a drink with him um
i've been i gave up office what five
years ago i think i've seen him
you know as i say a couple of times um
but socially so that it would be
captured by these rules or
uh formally minuted in these uh these
rules
well i don't know i i don't know exactly
how it's captured but i suspect if we
talked about any business things then
it would be captured by these rules okay
and then um can you give us a flavor
because obviously
everyone's remarked on the fact that
this was pretty intense pressure that
you were putting
on the system at the time is is that um
sort of characteristic of your normal
way of doing business is this something
that
if we were to look at your text messages
at any period of time you would be doing
a lot of very intensive contact of the
different parts of government or was
this
specific to the crisis um and the
pandemic and green cell
very much specific to the crisis um you
know it is worth
sort of going back and remembering that
moment when
as i say there was this sort of economic
heart stop and no one knew what was
going to happen next and the government
was
desperately trying to come up with the
right schemes and solutions to help make
sure that credit was there for
businesses and small businesses were
supported
and all the rest of it yeah and as i
said the the
reason behind the persistence issue is
that
first of all fintech is different it's
not so well understood i think that's
important
secondly i was very enthusiastic okay
about the scheme and i want to just take
sorry to interrupt but i only get so
much time and i've got quite a few other
questions i want to cover
really sorry um that one of the texts
that you
exchanged or what that message is you
exchanged with tom scholar um you said
uh something like you didn't understand
why the bank of england would be cutting
rates during a pandemic there's a bit uh
cut out of the
exchange um but reading it uh
in a way that we can see it um it sort
of reads as though
um you were being told by tom scholar
that there might be a bank of england
um meeting ahead of ahead of the
actual rate cup taking place i've been
rather baffled by this
um text message because i obviously you
know rate cuts are a very appropriate
thing to do at a time of difficulty i
think i'm a victim of
spell check here i think it was about a
vat
cut um but i can't complain they
wouldn't have been telling
you about it i think i was responding
to something that was in the news okay
um and but i think i might have been a
victim of my own
failure to spell but i think that was my
going back to the time my
i was less sure when anyway i think it
was that right okay
okay and um just to help me understand
the players here richard sharp can you
just describe is that the richard sharp
who
at the time was on the bank of england
financial policy that's a different
richardson i think though the richards
well it might be the same one but
uh he was i think drafted into the
treasury
as an adviser to rishi sunek
at the time of the crisis because he'd
been very involved
as i think a banker uh in the 2008
crisis and i think he had that
um as as so we're talking about the
former
goldman sachs banker who was a bank of
england
member of the financial policy committee
until march 31st 2019 that
that richard sharp right yeah so he uh i
just wanted to make sure it was the same
richard sharp we were talking about
and then um lawrence mann that's the
same lawrence man who worked for you
when you were in 10 downey street is now
your
chief of staff is that a role that's
paid for by the
taxpayer um i'm afraid it's it's
far worse for florence man he's been
working with me since 2005. um
and uh so he is my chief of staff he
worked for me in downing street working
in opposition
um my office is partly supported
by um the former prime minister's grant
and that goes towards
roles such as responding to public
inquiries and government business and
answering correspondence and other
things that go on
even though you're not prime minister
and i think that pays a
share of his it pays a proportion of his
salary but he's not a
civil servant and wouldn't be covered by
the civil service code
no he's an employee of my office
right um so in your analysis
and looking at the situation and the
lessons that our committee ought to draw
um in terms of the work of
officials at the treasury from their
interaction
uh during this period do you now regret
the fact that they said no something
that you pushed back on so heavily at
the time
well i think in the end they gave
very good reasons for why the scheme
that they'd introduced
couldn't be amended in the way that we
were suggesting
and crucially as i said earlier we took
too long to get to the right answer
of how to make the scheme work with
supply chain finance and i think by the
time we got
to that answer conditions in the credit
markets at ease and i think actually
it's in the evidence from the
treasury the treasury wrote a letter
saying you know not only do we think we
can't quite make your
scheme work but actually the credit
markets have changed and eased and so
therefore the situation
um for our customers at ease but i just
want i'm going to
give me you know i want to explain
because it's important part of my
motivation
the reason i thought our idea was such a
good one was of course the ccff what it
did was it
bought commercial paper debt for large
uk
corporates and that eased their credit
conditions and gave them cash to invest
in
it could be in paying a supplier it
could be in building a plant or whatever
the strength what we were suggesting was
if you backed supply chain finance bonds
as part of the ccff
every penny of that would go straight
into
paying the bills early of suppliers to
big corporates so we thought
you were that because
you know i wasn't enthusiastic about
this just because
um you know we wanted to to join in the
ccff i thought we'd actually found
something that was incredibly tailored
to a bit of the market that all of us as
public servants would want to serve with
the ability very upset when the
the answer came back no and you said you
know i'm going to call absolutely
everyone about this
so given what you know now are you
pleased or are you unhappy still about
that decision to say no
i think i mean the reason for being
baffled was really twofold one was that
this class of assets was included in
2008
and so i thought well if it worked in
2008 it seems rather odd we're not doing
it now i was
surprised by that and also i thought
that by the time we got to the final
answer of something that was
really tailored to british firms british
supply chains
putting that money into small businesses
i think that we had a
a great idea but you know looking back i
think in the ultimately i think the
treasury gave a very good explanation
for why
although this scheme as they put it
could have great merit and
could help a lot it was too different to
what the scheme
that their setup had originally intended
to do and as i said by the time we got
to the end of this iterative process and
you know green seal made a mistake by
taking too
long to get through that introduction
process by the time we got to the end of
it the credit markets
had eased up in any event and finally in
your message to richard sharp when you
said
good guy but can be on the cautious side
who are you referring to i think i was
referring to um charles roxborough but i
was making a
general point in that which is i mean
i'm a huge fan of our
impartial professional civil service and
i think you know throughout this
pandemic they've done
an extraordinary job the point i often
make to people
is and it's important part of being a
minister is there can be an inbuilt bias
against doing something because of
course if you're a civil servant
there is a worry about taking a step
doing something different
doing something and so you know
ministers i think it's important for
ministers to ask themselves
you know are we being creative inventive
enough and so that's that's what i was
referring did
charles roxborough and tom scholar come
to the right decision in this case
i i think they came to a very
justifiable decision it was a useful
iterative process
and as i said i think we took too long
to get to the right answer
and that is partly what explains uh the
fact that there were
you know a number of text messages and
emails i mean a lot of them were
sending the same brief to a number of
different people
making these these arguments
unfortunately i've taken too long too
okay thank you very much harriet and can
i go to javon please
thank you it's the next big scandal
waiting to happen
it's an issue that frankly crosses party
lines
and has tainted our politics for too
long
it's an issue that exposes the far too
cozy relationship between
politics government business and
money i'm talking about lobbying
and we all know how it works the lunches
the flights the hospitality the quiet
word in your ear
the ex-ministers and ex-advisors for
hire
helping big business find the right way
to get
its way mr cameron do you remember those
words
i do i made them in 2010 and we made
two very important changes and yes
you've already mentioned those do you
understand yes you have do you
understand the irony
of having used them given many of us
believe that the quote depicts your own
behavior with green sill
well let me explain because i haven't
mentioned one of the changes that we
made because it was
important which is when i made those
remarks there'd just been i think a
lobbying scandal involving a firm that
was approached by a journalist
pretending to be from the government of
uzbekistan and the lobbying firm in
question said we can get you into
ministers we can get you to see people
and no one needs to know
who you are lobbying on behalf of and so
the change that the lobbying act brought
in i know it's criticized now but the
change the lobbying act brought protein
which was to make sure that multi-client
lobbyists had to register
who their clients were that was an
important change because it put a stop
to that problem and if you combine it
with the issue of being having to report
the meetings that ministers have
you've got two very valuable tools in
making sure that people can see
who is lobbying whom and on whose behalf
and as i said in my interactions from
greensell to the government
i absolutely knew that if the meetings i
wanted to take place
did take place they would be properly
reported on
and everyone would know about them and
that is absolutely right and of course
before you i'm never so sorry
but this is a meeting to ask you
questions
rather than to allow you to talk for the
next two hours
you had the enormous privilege of being
the prime minister of our great country
you're one of only five post people
post-war
to have been re-elected to lead our
government
do you not feel that you have demeaned
yourself
and your position by what's up in your
way around whitehall on the back of a
fraudulent enterprise
based on selling bonds of high-risk debt
to unsuspecting investors
well my view is that what i did was i
made a choice to
work for a business which i hoped would
be a uk fintech
success story and many people believe
that it would and i wanted to help that
company grow and expand
and what i did at the time of economic
crisis was put to the government what i
genuinely believed
to be a good idea for how to get money
into the hands of small businesses and
get their bills paid early
i've said that you know looking back and
now looking forward
you know ex-prime ministers are in a
very important and different position
and so a single letter or email would be
more appropriate
but we were in very different
circumstances when covid happened
but do you not think that you were
presenting a business that had
fundamental
financial problems and the efforts were
in order to fill the holes in that
business rather than help the british
taxpayer
my interaction with the government is
because i genuinely believed
these were good ideas to help small
businesses and if you look at the
like of course this business went into
administration it failed and we need to
learn the lessons from that and there
are lots of
lessons and i look forward to reading
what your committee has to say about it
but
what i don't accept is that it was a
business that was predetermined to fail
at its heart was a simple and good idea
which is to go to large corporate
companies like airbus with 26 000
suppliers you don't believe it was a
ponzi scheme because that's what lord
miners told us
if you take the airbus example which was
a leading client of
green sill we were paying that 25 000
suppliers
instantly getting cash into tens of
thousands of small businesses
and then airbus would pay back green
sill and a bond would be floated in the
meantime that idea
of using technology and deep capital
markets
help small businesses that is a good
idea
as recently as tuesday mr greenstall who
you seem to be
painting as a reincarnation of the late
mother teresa
told the committee that this was a great
business
only brought down by unreasonable and
greedy insurance companies
we now know that 90 percent of greens
green sales business was lending against
transactions
that have never happened may never
happen
and with companies that don't even know
that they are involved
and then selling it on at low risk mr
cameron
do you still believe that that business
model was a good one
what i believe is that the the key idea
of supply chain finance of going to
big companies and saying we will pay
your suppliers
early get cash into those businesses
that that
is a good idea and the companies that
greensville work with like
vodafone and astrazeneca and ford motor
company
and airbus big responsible employers
big important companies cameron do you
know what a perspective receivable is
well i've listened very carefully to the
evidence you've been hearing over
uh previous days and the concept of
perspective didn't involve any of the
companies you just listed
well let's deal with future receivables
which i think is
the correct term and future receivables
were involved in the supply chain
finance scheme that i helped to set up
in government which was the way that the
nhs
under this scheme pharmacies were paid
early and pharmacists
are very small when during the height of
the crisis you were bothering ministers
and civil servants
did you know that 90 percent of green
sales business
represented unsecured loans to high-risk
borrowers
and half the time without any invoice
whatsoever
well that's not a figure i recognized i
listened to mr greenspan's evidence to
you on tuesday where he talked about
future receivables being perhaps 20 of
the business
and i think when it comes to future
receivables it is important to
recognize that in the case of the nhs
and the pharmacies scheme
can i just ask you a question about the
nhs
turning now to greensource proposals for
our nhs
an app named earned to pay doctors and
nurses
daily or weekly in advance do you accept
that your lobbying of the nhs
wasn't for its health but for the health
of green sales spanish balance
sheet um i wouldn't accept that for one
second
because the whole concept of earned in
the nhs was that it was going to be free
to
not just the employee but also free to
the nhs
itself why i thought this was so
attractive
is that you know i remember probably
answering questions from you
about the evils of payday lending and
the idea that
staff in the nhs can draw down their
salary as they earn it
rather than have to wait till the end of
the month i think that could go some way
to ending the use of payday lending and
of course this is really
cameron green cells green salt green
souls own
administration documents make clear
and i quote the commercial rationale for
providing
these services without profit was to
create
critical mass to enable earned uk
to sell to corporate entities to
generate revenues
and to provide cross-selling
opportunities
to the wider group so i ask you again
do you now accept that your lobbying of
the nhs was about a commercial incentive
for green cell now i don't accept that
because
it's nothing sacred no from green cell's
point of view this was part of its
corporate social responsibility program
was saying
to the nhs this is going to be free not
just to the doctors and nurses
but free to the nhs trusts as well and
of course it left green cell free uh to
sell to corporate entities to generate
revenues and to provide cross-selling
opportunities to the wider group
not my words green souls words that you
asked me about
thank you thank you
very much uh siobhan i'm going to go to
julie now please
thank you very much mr cameron
um i'd like to go back and explore in a
bit more detail something you refer to
in your opening statement and i think is
something of a thread
throughout this this session which is
your particular position as a former
prime minister um former prime ministers
are quite a rare
and and uh exceptional breed um when we
heard from lord
macpherson a couple of weeks ago from
this um
committee he said that generally prime
minister's
former prime ministers don't generally
contact the treasury
it's it's quite exceptional they might
say you know
check up some records or issues
relating to your time in office but but
actually
to talk about policy to to lobby is is
quite exceptional
would would you accept that it really is
quite an exceptional
um uh course of action that you took
over this period well these were
exceptional times when
you know business was uniquely
threatened no one knew what was going to
happen to the economy
and i knew from my own experience of
being that the government was
considering
what sort of loan support schemes what
sort of loan guarantee schemes what
would work and so
these were extraordinary times and as
i've said i think you know
it would be better for next prime
minister in future
and i will certainly abide by this if
you're contacting the government about
any commercial issue then this would be
a very rare event to
to send one formal letter or one formal
email but i think these were
um exceptional times
lord macpherson also said for example if
if
a former prime minister did contact
government
department it would usually be
potentially on a broader point of policy
but isn't the point here that the
point of policy that you were talking
about was something in which you had a
very specific
economic interest has been referenced
previously
well it was something that i was
passionate about because i thought that
it could really help
small businesses and supply chains in
the united kingdom so
that was why i was so keen to contact
the government
as i've said i know what it's like when
you're searching for things that will
help
business when credit markets dry up when
there's difficulties in the economy
and i thought we had a very good answer
and i was very keen as i said for it to
be listened to because
the banks are quite rightly on speed
dial with the treasury everyone knows
you know when troubles hit and i think
paul miners in his evidence to you said
that he would often be talking
you know to ten uh bank chairman and
chief executive every week in that sort
of situation
and i think it is important to recognize
the change in
patterns of lending where you've now got
fintech firms and non-bank financial
institutions extending
huge amounts of credit to small
businesses it's very important to have
that conversation as well
do you accept that you are different to
a bank
chief executive and do you think that
that that
is a different circumstance and and did
you ever
consider the impact that that would have
on the people receiving the calls and
the letters and the emails and so on
of course i i thought very carefully
before picking up the telephone and i
thought the
circumstances warranted it because they
were unique but i've
you know reflected since then and
thought you know in future as i said
it'd be much better
one single communication but i think
these were
exceptional times and that's why i think
it was acceptable to do
what i did and i think i mean it's very
important to listen to nick mcpherson
have great respect for him but i
i'm sure you'll also hear from tom
scholar and from
charles roxburgh who said in their
evidence that you know
there was no improper they didn't feel
improper pressure they thought it was
right to consider this sort of scheme
it could be made to work you know and
the bank of england have pretty much
said
i'm the same thing so i don't think they
were bent out of shape
in terms of their resources and the sort
of time they spent on this
and i have said that i think you know we
took too long to get the right answer
and that that was
frustrating for for for me uh as as well
as for them but uh
they've said that the you know talking
to business
is part of what they do and and you know
you said
quite rightly uh we all remember it you
know you've been at the dispatch box
you have been on the receiving end of
lobbying and ideas and so on
to what extent do you think it's fair
that someone
as a former prime minister with the
range of experience the knowledge of the
system
the contacts and so on that they that
you should have that same level of
access and that same ability to
influence um and lobby well i think it's
a very good question as i said in my
opening statement maybe there is a case
for a longer period of time before
there's
any commercial contact between an
ex-prime minister
and a department i've also thought
carefully i noticed that gordon brown i
think said there should be
no no contact whatsoever on a commercial
issue i
i would stop one short from that because
i could
potentially imagine gordon brown or john
major being
you know chairman of a big bank or
british telecom or some strategically
important british company and i think
the idea of there being no contact
then between a former politician and the
government wouldn't make sense i mean
for instance as prime minister i used to
meet very regularly with bob dudley he
was the chair of bp
you know i think that's right you've got
strategically important companies
that do need to talk to government and
while it's very important we regulate
lobbying properly while it's very
important we report meetings
transparently
while it's important we look at all
those rules we mustn't get to a
situation where
you know the public sector is cut off
from the private sector so
you know yes ex-prime ministers are
different yes we need to think and act
differently
yes there are lessons to learn i
completely accept that
but but don't i wouldn't go quite as far
as gordon brown although
i agree with him about many things
so is it fair is it would you accept a
criticism to say
that you you are putting forward some
potential solutions and
lessons to be learning from this that if
you had perhaps been more self
you know aware or self-aware and
cognizant of potentially the impact
of the lobbying from a former prime
minister from yourself that
that we wouldn't have to be looking at
changing the rules at this point
or more rules well i would i would say
two things to that the first is that
um clearly these civil servants were not
intimidated by getting a call from me or
from looking
at this uh proposal from dealing with
green seal and the fintech sector
they if you look at what they said to
the public accounts committee
they thought it was appropriate and they
got on and looked at the
scheme i think um that's the
the first thing um and uh
as i say i think you know ex-prime
ministers
are different and i think we we should
be looking at the rules just because
there's no harm in in trying to work out
is there more you could do i mean i
think
acaba as a process which i've been
through with a number of different
appointments it does work well
um but i can see an argument that says
you know for an ex-prime minister where
you you've got to make choices when you
leave office and i made a series of
choices and
about the charities i'd work with and
the businesses i support
perhaps there is a role for a sort of a
committee of some
uh former permanent secretaries and
people with great business experience to
give give advice on that because
there isn't really a road map for a
ex-prime minister
perhaps particularly for a younger one
who doesn't just want to
you know be on the board of some big
bank and make the old speech around the
world but who wants to get stuck in and
help a business grow and expand
perhaps there there could be a role for
that sort of committee to give that sort
of advice and
perhaps i would have found that
beneficial thank you and can i
just turn to the um the the relationship
between yourself and
lex greensell uh during this period
you've mentioned
some strategic objectives that that you
felt you had
in joining greenfield could you could
you just give us a feel for
how much direction on a day-to-day basis
a week-to-week basis you had from lex
green sill um both um in sort of what we
might call normal times and then as it
became more of a crisis
moment um when i was
contracted to work with the business for
a number of days every year
i think i comfortably exceeded that
because i was enthusiastic about what
this company was doing
i'd probably talk to lex greenseal once
a week
um and the sort of work we were doing
was
trying to win new clients uh whether in
the uk or
elsewhere we were looking at how to
expand best into
new territories i think he said in his
evidence that
while i was working for the business we
increased by 50 or 100 the number of
countries we were operating in
um i would try and help him with some of
the key relationships with
um suppliers companies like oracle and
sap who are crucial to the way the
business work so it was really helping
with expansion as well as the sort of
more traditional
advisory role about geopolitical and
uh other advice so that's the sort of it
was a good relationship i enjoyed
working with the company i'm extremely
sorry and sad that it has come to this
end
clearly as he said there were faults
with the business there were
vulnerabilities that weren't
properly addressed but i repeat again i
think we mustn't get into this situation
in this country where
just because a business goes into
administration it doesn't mean that
everything about it was wrong it doesn't
mean the whole thing was some
giant necessarily giant fraud you know
there were i think
very strong important parts to supply
chain finance that can have a real
social
benefit that's why i joined the company
in the first place for example
during um perhaps more of the crisis
period would let screensales say to you
would you would you phone up rishi sunak
would you text him would you would you
get on the to the treasury would you get
on to him at hancock would you
would he direct you and give you
particular you know uh
missions or objectives in in that kind
of way
no the conversations that we had um i
think started
with the chairman of the bank of england
making this remark about the importance
of supporting supply chains
during the pandemic and i think in one
of our conversations
you know i said i'd try and find out
more about what was
meant by that when it came to this issue
of our proposal to improve
the ccff with this supply chain finance
idea which as i've said would be
we thought very targeted because all the
money would go
to small and medium-sized businesses it
was then a question of of well
what's the best way of trying to get
this in front of government and that is
what i helped with and
i helped with that because it was a
moment of crisis and i believed it was a
good idea
so i don't want to put words in your
mouth but would i would we be
characterizing that in that case that
really uh you you self-directed you made
the judgments on
who to lobby when to lobby them and how
often to lobby them for example
well i had the discussions with with him
and perhaps one or two others
um so i could properly understand
how the ccff was meant to work what our
proposal would do
to improve it and how best to try and
get government to um
at least consider it thank you very much
chair i think i'm out of time thank you
mr cameron
thank you thank you julie and emma
please thank you chair and good
afternoon mr
cameron uh just a couple of quick
questions at the beginning um has the
chancellor published
every sms or whatsapp message that he
sent you in relation to greensell
i believe he has yes okay thank you did
you and the chancellor speak over the
phone about greensville's cc
ffrc bills yes
did you speak on the 18th of may i'd
have to check the
records but um i think we we definitely
did speak
um i think possibly a couple of times
but i've got i think it's all in the
return i sent to the committee
okay could you tell us what was
discussed what i was discussing with him
from memory was you know my contention
that the ccff was a brilliant idea
because it was helping large
british-based corporates to have
access to cash and credit at a time of
difficulty
and how including supply chain finance
bonds in that facility would be even
more effective because every penny of
that money would go
um into small businesses so i was very
passionate about it i thought it was a
really good idea and i think i was
you know drawing as i said on my
experience as prime minister when
some you announced didn't quite work the
way you
were okay i'm just going through these
quite quickly just on that conversation
on the 18th
of may were the treasury officials
dialed in or was it a private
conversation between you and the
chancellor
i don't know you'd have to ask the
chance of that i don't think there was
anyone listening my end
um but uh there might well have been uh
his end
okay just just earlier on actually in
response to one of my colleagues
you said something about that you didn't
believe that the resources of the
treasury were bent
out of shape with the time spent or
resources
do you accept that 56 lobbying attempts
of ministers
and officials during a pandemic when as
you've already said the economy was on
life support
when the treasury was working 24 7. and
we've heard evidence
earlier that time spent responding to
your lobbying
means time not respect spent responding
to other areas of need
companies in need and the indeed regions
in need around the rest of the country
have you never reflected back and
considered that you maybe went over the
top
well i i would draw very heavily on what
charles roxburg said at the public
accounts committee when he
said in answering a question that was
not a disproportionate use of time at
all
had the proposal proved workable it
could have been a way to support a large
number
of small businesses at a time of crisis
and he also makes the point that
the proposal that was come up with uh
ultimately resulted in a
consultation with 10 other supply chain
finance companies
and that it was a useful exercise as i
say i
i definitely accept that one of the
reasons for the persistence was that
we took too long to get the best
possible scheme
to the government and that was our fault
for which we should take responsibility
but
the civil servants from what i've heard
are saying this was an interesting
proposal
it's our job to engage with business it
didn't take up disproportionate amount
of times
at a time and if it could have worked um
it would have been a good exercise
with respect and mr cameron i wasn't
asking what you believed the opinion of
the civil servants to be i was asking
what
your opinion is do you believe that 56
attempts of lobbying during a pandemic
using treasury ministers and officials
time that could have been spelt
spent elsewhere was a useful use of
their time i'm not asking you at the
civil service thing i'm asking whether
you've reflected on it
and what you think i have reflected on
it
um and i think it was a time of
extraordinary crisis
and so it was a time when i think it was
appropriate to
use phone intent email and letter
but i think in future one of the lessons
i take away is
that prime ministers should only ever
use
a letter or email and should restrict
themselves far more
but the reason for quoting the civil
servants is in a way
that's the answer to the question i mean
if they're saying
we weren't putting disproportionate time
we weren't
bent out of shape then i think that is a
significant
and important point did the chancellor
tell you what the
quote alternative was that he quote
pushed his officials to explore on your
behalf
i think from memory that that's
the treasury made the treasury on the
bank of england made a proposal for
how supply chain finance could be
included in the ccff and they
put that to green sill and others um
but greenston and others didn't think
that it would work
in the form that was put forward so this
is why i mean one of the reasons there
were
all these contacts was it was an
iterative process the original green
seal proposal an amended proposal
a proposal from the government you know
it went through a lot of phases and
that's i think set out in the
evidence to you from the bank of england
and the treasury
and i think what that text refers to
is the government's proposal back
to the supply chain finance providers
okay just to take
one day for example on the third of
april you received some bad news
the treasury did not intend to revise
the terms of the ccff
from what we can tell on the same day
you what's up the chance of the
exchequer you called the economic
secretary to the treasury
you called the downing street spad you
emailed the deputy governor at the bank
of england you also texted michael gove
and tom scholar
all in all there were two calls and 16
written communications on a single day
to six different people all of whom have
had other things to do
in the midst of a rapidly developing
crisis the following day you secured a
call with the chancellor
do you still think this was appropriate
well i think it was a time when the
government was looking at
what schemes can actually get cash to
businesses
and work and we believe we had one of
those schemes we thought it was worth
a proper look and of course you know as
i said it went through an iterative
process where they came back with
a proposal um so i think it you know but
as i say
standing back from it looking back at it
now you know i do understand that
ex-prime ministers have to be very
careful about what they do and very
careful about
uh the measures they take and in normal
times
and i will certainly restrict myself to
this if ever there's an occasion and i
doubt there will be but if ever there's
occasion when
a business has a commercial proposition
to put to government
it will be a single letter or email okay
the final point earlier on you said that
you usually put
love bc on the bottom of your text and
therefore you were explaining this shows
no
particular closeness or relationship
with tom scholar
but from what we can see from all the
other texts that you sent it doesn't
appear
anywhere else to love dc even on your
text to michael gove and to wishy
soon after so was it was do you want to
sort of reflect on whether or not you
want to
talk about the relationship you had with
tom scholar
i think i've accurately um reflected
the relationship with thomas scott i
mean i'm i'm very happy to check out how
many times i've met him
socially since i left office in 2016. i
think it is
two um so the two in
five years is is not a huge amount
um i i i don't know rishi
sunak that well we were in parliament
together for uh for a period of time but
i don't know him that well but i
i do i think i can i can produce a list
of
um friends and relations who have loved
dc on the
end of their text messages yes but just
maybe not love
dc to michael gove um thank you chair
thank you thanks very much uh emma and
can i go to felicity
now please thank you chair and good
afternoon good to see you
um you mentioned in your opening remarks
that you thought carefully before taking
the role at greensville
and that you took advice from a wide
number of people
can i ask you specifically what due
diligence
you did do on green sill before
accepting the role
and how familiar you were with their
business
and their business model i did think
about it
very carefully um i consulted
a couple of very senior business leaders
who are
people i worked with when in government
i talked to
i think two financial analysts who asked
their view about the company
i met with not just lecturing so but
with the chairman of the company morris
thompson someone who has
i think 30 years of experience in in
british banking and
finance i met with the venture
capitalist
john gorman who had originally invested
in
in next greenfield and was still working
with him
um and uh obviously i asked lots of
questions of the company
about every aspect of the business from
the road of insurance
to the way the credit suites and other
funds work
to the list of customers but i think to
be
frank one of the things i took the
greatest comfort from was
general atlantic who i usually admire as
an investor
they had just invested in the business
and this company had as
customers people like um airbus and
vodafone and astrazeneca
and had partnerships with companies like
credit suisse and oracle and others so
it was a mixture of all those things but
i certainly did do
um quite a lot of due diligence and
asked a lot of questions and tried to
make sure i
understood at the core to what of what
the business was doing
now to me there were several red flags
about this business even back then
one was the exposure that it had
to gupta and his family of companies and
indeed the interdependence between
greensville
and gupta and his companies and then
clearly
gam and tim haywood had been in the
press
just a month before in july 2018
were you aware of those issues and did
they give you concern at the time
yes of course i was aware of them i
think taking them
separately on the gam issue um
that was reported widely in the
newspapers
i asked a lot of questions about it got
a lot of reassurances
about it it's a complicated issue but
ultimately
one of the funds that was closed all the
investors received their
money back and there was a gam green
sill supply chain fund that continued to
operate
i believe successfully pretty much
throughout the time that i was working
for the
company and of course the credit suisse
funds at the same time were expanding
and so one of the key questions for the
company was
have you got the distribution potential
for these assets you're creating
um from financial from the finances
you're providing to small businesses
and the list of banks that was buying
these um was growing and there were the
other funds so i think that
i asked questions about i thought was
important but i thought i got
um satisfactory answers the issue of
cons of client concentration and
specifically
on gupta and glg
i think this this had you know this was
something i did ask about
before joining and asked a lot of
questions about while i was there
the reassurance i always got was that
there was a plan
to deal with this concentration and over
time reduce this
concentration but obviously that is not
something that happened
satisfactorily and i think you know has
uh i think you heard that from mr
greenslaw when he gave his
evidence that um it's an important
concern
and did your view of the company change
over time was there anything that
concerned you
over time well the time you know i
joined the company in august 2018 just
after the general atlantic
investment where of course they've done
an enormous amount of due diligence
and then during the time i was working
for the company there was this big
softbank investment now
i know softbank and the vision fund
isn't everybody's
cup of tea but nonetheless you know they
are a heavyweight
investor and again do a lot of due
diligence and the number of
partnerships and customers seem to be
growing in a
healthy way i mean my as i
tried to say to one of your colleagues
you know my enthusiasm for this business
was very simply based on the idea
that if you team up with large
corporates you pay their suppliers early
you're pumping money into small
businesses and anyone who goes anywhere
near a small business knows that
cash flow and credit and and working
capital are
absolutely crucial to their success and
survival that is why i
um believe this was a worthwhile
business and so the more we could add
those big
corporate clients many of which were
added while i was working with the
company i thought the stronger the
company would be
but clearly this company has failed if
you work for a
company that goes into administration
you you you look back
and think of all the different choices
you could have made and of course i'm
i'm i'm doing that
but as i say during the period i was
working for it there were good signs of
strengthening
um but there was this issue of gupta
which
i don't think you know was adequately
dealt with and that became a a looming
problem
and clearly the business model here was
to uh have the receivables package them
up with credit insurance
and then on sell them to credit suisse
asset management
and then to investors were you aware
in september the tokyo marine had
decided
not to renew the credit insurance
because again that would be a flag
to me that the business model wasn't
real jeopardy
well i wasn't a director of the company
and i wasn't on the credit or risk
committees i
i don't think i was aware of the
deadline with tokyo marine
i listened every week to the um
sort of company podcast that was
describing how the company was going and
there seemed to be a good position with
28
insurers i think it was and a number of
new insurers coming on board
so i don't think i was aware about that
looming deadline i mean one point i make
is
you know when you're an advisor to a
company but not a director one of the
things you
you know ask yourself is does this
company have
an effective legal function does it have
an effective credit committee
risk committee um audit committee
is it a strong board and the answer to
all those questions
seemed to be to me to be pretty positive
and of course as an advisor not a
director you take
comfort from that and just on that point
were you concerned that the chair had
come
from citibank where mr greensell had
worked
and perhaps the chair was not
sufficiently independent i'm not
making an allegation and saying that he
wasn't but i am aware that they worked
together in the past
i i i from what i saw of how morris
thompson worked i thought he was a
you know he had this extraordinary long
experience in
banking and finance not just at citibank
but at warburgs i think
before he was a very effective chairman
i think he
you know held the management to account
from what i could see
effectively and again you know when
you're thinking about being an advisor
to a company that's one of the questions
you ask is is the capabilities of the
chairman and the people on the board
yes and can i just ask you about your
role with clients you said
that part of your mission was to go out
there and win
new business i do believe that you
actually went to visit
the credit insurers in australia
what was the nature of that visit and
that meeting
that that meeting was really a sort of
uh general
catch up and getting to know you meeting
i was in australia
i think speak i was giving a lecture
tour to
um a um australian
jewish organization um and because i was
in australia and lex greens was in
australia he said
i think we did a meeting with some
clients and prospective clients
um and we also went to see this insurer
but it was it was not a
you know significant business meeting it
was just a
you know getting to know checking in
with and for me to get to know them
and did you meet a mr brerton there who
was subsequently farred as my
understanding for
exceeding his risk limits to greensboro
i don't remember exactly who i met i'd
have to
i mean i may have already thought of it
i may not i understand
and um i believe your office has denied
this but there have been reports that mr
greensell was offering up
meetings with you almost as rewards
if people in government accept in
meetings with him can you just
categorically
say that you were not aware of that
practice certainly
not aware of that um you know i would
carry out a lot of meetings
um for the company um whether it was
with customers or suppliers or partners
or what have you but i'm
not aware of that at all yes and i'm
being told that my time is up so just
one
final question do you regret
your involvement with green still and as
you look forward because you're clearly
still
a very young man and may take on
other opportunities uh will you take on
more commercial opportunities going
forward is that something that you still
have on your agenda
well i think when you work for a company
that goes into administration
as i said you look back and and you know
you think
what different choices could i have made
all i can say to this committee is
you know my real focus since leaving
office has been things like
alzheimer's and dementia and fragile
states and the commission that i
chair and i wanted to have a range of
business interests as well
i mean i chose greensboro because i
thought it was an exciting uk-based
tech company uh that would be
you know rolled up sleeves working in
rather than
just a brass nameplate on the door um
obviously you know what's happened is
deeply regrettable
and it's very you know being part of a
company that goes into administration is
is i mean it's depressing but never mind
me it's you know for the people who've
lost their jobs
they had whole futures invested in
you know this company being their future
and it's incredibly depressing to see it
go wrong in terms of my own
situation i think i'll probably have
some commercial interest but
i've got a lot of work on uh with
dementia
i chair the early diagnosis board for
how we can try
and diagnose dementia earlier and
therefore
find the cure and i think that's the
most important mission i've got
at the moment and maybe now we'll have
even more time to pursue it
thank you thanks felicity um angela
please
thank you very much mr cameron i've read
your 56
messages uh and they're more like
stalking than lobbying looking back
aren't you at least
a little bit embarrassed about the way
you behaved
as i said it was a you know particularly
acute time in the british economy
the government was introducing plans to
try and help businesses
we thought we had a good idea i was keen
to get it in front of government but as
i said there are
lessons to learn and lessons for me to
learn and in future the single
formal email or formal letter um would
be
appropriate but okay it was a particular
i think it's it's
easy to forget now just what a sort of
time of economic shock
it was many of us don't forget there
were thousands of people dying at the
time and the country was in
a serious situation now you've said your
role at greensell was as an advisor
but did you ever write to nhsx
describing yourself as a director of the
company
i think there was an email which um uh
i've seen where i think i described bill
carruthers as a fellow director and it
was a mistake
and if that's the one you're referring
to that was a mistake i wasn't a
director of the company
uh i was an advisor and as i said i
didn't sit on
any of those sort of um subcommittees of
the board that are so important
did you write do the same in writing to
counterparties in australia
i do yourself as a director i don't
believe i did no
will you undertake to check your records
and keep the committee informed of
the outcome of a check that you do on
that of course
thank you very much mr greenstall told
me that
you had an outstanding invite to board
meetings and that you attended regularly
you've said today you attended regularly
and that you uh and that you
had a lot to say at some of those board
meetings
do you know what a shadow director is
under
section two five one one of the
companies act 2006
and are you aware of the consequences of
you being found to be a shadow director
well i'm i am aware um i'm not a lawyer
but my understanding of this is the
shadow director
issue is when you have a company that
has a a board but the real person
controlling that company is actually not
on the board
and that is what the concept of the
shadow director is and
in my case there's actually no question
that i was in any way
controlling this company while not being
on the board so i don't think
and that applies to me at all okay
at the time you started your incredibly
frenetic
lobbying of the chancellor were you
aware that
barton the german regulator had given
green seal instructions to reduce their
loan concentration to gupta
i don't believe that i was but again i
may have to
check the records but i don't that
wasn't discussed at
the meetings that you attended the board
i don't believe so but i can certainly
go back and check i mean i think it's an
important question what was the closest
board meeting
before the pandemic struck and i don't
recall
um off the top of my head but i i don't
remember that but i
i don't want to give an accurate answer
so again perhaps you could
check and get back to us about that were
you aware that most of the
coronavirus interruption business loans
made by greenfield bank were to gupta
names and friends
which is actually increasing green cells
concentration
and exposure to gupta rather than
reducing it
well as i said i wasn't on the credit
committee so i wasn't responsible for
extending any credit any loan to any
client including
mr gupta so i didn't know about the
exact nature of those loans now
and these things weren't discussed at
the boards meetings that you attended
i mean did the credit and
committees not give reports at the board
of directors would you not have heard
some of that
while you were attending board meetings
i don't i don't remember that i remember
with the um
ccff there was a lot of discussion
outside the board because this was
happening in real time
and it was a very good scheme the
government had set up that we had this
proposal to amend in terms of the other
schemes
there were discussions as i understand
it between green seal
and the british business bank
discussions which i wasn't involved in
at all of the process of being an
accredited
lender i'm sure they were reported back
to board meetings but it's not something
i had any involvement in
okay now lex green cell told me that you
were a paye
employee of the company uh how much were
you paid for that role you
you gave us a hint a bit earlier saying
it was more than you earned as prime
minister
uh is it more than boris johnson earned
when he was on the back benches can you
give us
more of a ballpark figure i was well
paid
in terms of the annual amount and i had
these shares but as i said to your
chairman i think it's important for the
committee to know i had that economic
interest i was committed to this company
i wanted to
work for it i would benefit if the
company succeeded but all the questions
you're
asking and addressing quite rightly in
your committee about
about lobbying and about this behavior
and what ex-prime ministers should do
and how the treasury work
i don't think they're affected by the
amount
um of it and so i i don't consider i i
would consider that a private matter
but perhaps um mr cameron given that
this company
collapsed that it took we know at least
400 million pounds of government-backed
loans via
the british business bank with it that
it's cost between one and three
billion pounds of taxpayers money that
there are german towns suffering because
of the
uh stricken nature of the green seal
bank in germany
don't you think that what you were
earning and how it motivated
your personal lobbying of government
is a matter of public interest well
what i would say is that my motivation
in talking to the government was about
how to introduce a scheme that i thought
would benefit
small businesses but likewise you you
but you if
if this gap bank had actually floated
successfully you would have been a
multi-millionaire wouldn't you
but i'd also make the point that i mean
lex green said himself probably
talked to the government in terms of
meetings he had more than i did
and when he was in front of you on
tuesday you didn't think it was relevant
to ask what he earned or what his shares
were i mean i think the point is the
same which is
yes i had an economic interest in this
company i was committed to the company i
was paid by it i had shares in it i
wanted it to succeed
but i think the actual quantum of it i i
don't think is actually relevant to
answering the questions that you have to
answer
and do you and have you paid uk tax on
your earnings or are you keeping them
offshore yeah they're all all tax has
been paid on them and uh
i don't uh it's all onshore what are
these no
it was reported reporting the wall
street journal today that you made
several
million dollars from cashing out stock
options in 2019
is that is that true uh and again have
you kept all of those
uh earnings on shore and paid tax on
that everything i've done
i've paid full uk tax on whether that is
capital gains tax or income tax i don't
have any
money offshore i have a office of david
cameron
which i fund through some of the work
that i do
and i earn some money in a personal
capacity but
every uh proper tax is paid income and
capital gains
can i just ask you about prospective
receivables you you seem
like mr greensell was reluctant to
recognize
that phrase and talk about future
receivables
instead yet that phrase does feature in
court documents in america
and it also features uh in uh
correspondence that mr gupta had with
the financial times
uh over uh fraudulent invoices it seems
uh that uh were securitized by green
sill
how much do you know about prospective
receivables
and how much was greenfield bank
involved
in securitizing phantom invoices
well i think you know you you got
answers from
lex queensland on tuesday who was
running the business and who was
involved in these credit and other
decisions uh
he explained that he thought the term
was future receivables rather than
prospective receivables the point i
would make is
and i think he said that only 20 percent
of the business was
future receivables rather than actual
receivables
but i think the example he gave and i'm
happy to give a couple of others is that
there's nothing abnormal about providing
finance on the basis of
future receivables i mean when uh
the nhs i i i agree with that
so long as they're predictable but
actually
gupta was talking about prospective
receivables not future receivables and
we do know that green cell had a pretty
twisted symbiotic relationship with
gupta
well i think that i i heard mr
greensworld's evidence where he said
that you know
all um financing had to be based on
actual invoices and and not of course
any
fake invoices and that's a very
important consideration but i think
your committee will have to think about
how to answer this but
what i wouldn't do is to say that
all financing on the basis of future
receivables is a bad idea i mean the
i wouldn't say that but
invoices are a bad idea of course we
knew that that would be a very serious
accusation okay and finally how many
times
did you use one of the green silver's
fleet of private planes to fly to or
from
uh newquay close to your third home
or any other non-business declarations
and
what is your estimate of the value of
your use of the greenfield
fleet and have you declared these as
taxable benefits
um i haven't got a complete record of uh
the use of of planes i mean it was used
quite a lot by
lex green sill and senior managers and
sometimes myself
on business visits and i did use it a
handful of times
on uh other visits and of course
all proper taxes and all those things
would be dealt with in the proper way
thank you chair
thank you very much angela and going now
to anthony
please uh thank you chair and uh
thank you david cameron for coming to
give evidence to our committee um i just
want to follow a couple of questions
that uh uh andrew eagle's asking about
about the prospective receivables
um the uh and i completely support
you know what you say about the role of
supply chain finance i myself have
helped promote it uh and securitizing
supply chain finance
assets is not necessarily an issue and
doing future
um receivables such as with the uh
with the pharmacies not an issue at all
the issue here is where
there have been a lot of stories in the
media about grant thornton the
administrator coming across
uh trying to unravel all this and coming
across uh
invoices uh where the companies that are
supposedly issued invoices said they had
absolutely no
uh commercial arrangement uh with uh
liberty commodities with
with gupta uh and they certainly think
they seem to be
uh fraudulent or they were um
uh and we don't know whether they were
made up by the
the uh gupta or whether whether green
seal knew about this or not
when you must have read these reports
and you must be concerned about what was
going on under the bonnet there even if
you didn't know it at the time
no well the recent reports that have
come out about this are
are clearly very disturbing if if true
as i say i wasn't involved in credit
extension
not to gupta but to any company that
wasn't part of my
role but obviously there's a difference
between
future receivables known cash flows for
instance
your mobile phone in your pocket you pay
for
with the contract and uh that is a sort
of future receivable if you like
there's a difference between that and
something that you know non-existent
prospective clients that you know
haven't even been contacted yet that is
a different
uh different thing so look uh i i don't
know
any more than you do about that i've
read that in the newspapers it seems
concerning
and i'm sure that it needs to be got to
the bottom and some of the previous
witnesses have had
said that i've been securitizing these
uh invoices that
where the companies actually don't have
any commercial arrangement with
uh with liberty with gupta uh and
securitizing them and then selling them
one as assets that's i mean they're
quite clear this is
very strong appearance basically
unfortunate um
i mean how concerned are you uh about
that that actually they're
fundamentally here there was a large
amount of fraud going on
well i certainly you know haven't seen
any evidence of that myself directly i
thought
mr greensteal sort of explained the
difference between they avoided
all receivables purity that goes with
future receivables
the role of insurance um but obviously
you know
that is uh if if what is being suggested
is
is true then that property needs to be
looked at
some of the uh evidence we've been
taking earlier was really about the role
of financial regulation here and supply
chain finance as you know isn't
regulated and uh the green cell itself
has
the important point there which is you
know um
business lending isn't regulated i think
it'd be wrong to sort of signal out
supply
single out supply chain finally yeah
supply chain finance is trying to hide
in some sort of dark
corner it is a form of business lending
and business lending isn't regulated
you're the expert here having run the
british bankers
association so there are arguments about
how to better extend and use regulation
but i think it's important to me
yeah yeah no absolutely and there's very
you know
lending from one company to another is
uh regulated it
is under civil contract law it's between
two uh professional partners it isn't
regulated by the financial conduct
authority the principles of regulation
are either
generally consumer protection uh or um
to positive protection if it's a bank
and neither of those apply to business
lending or supply chain finance
what my question though really is and
one of the remits of our inquiry here
the treasury select committee is to
learn if there are any lessons for
financial regulation and i obviously
weren't
um uh the chancellor directly
responsible financial regulation we ran
a government that did a huge amount of
financial re-regulation
and from your involvement in this are
there from your point of view and what
you've learned
are there any uh lessons to be learnt
about financial regulations or suggested
changes that you think you
the government should look at well i
think i've listened to the evidence that
you've had this week
i think the fca made some very good
points about the
ar regime um i think the points mr
greensteal made about
credit insurance important
i think what the fca said about
even if there isn't greater regulation
having better information
um not least so that you can see when
something might become systemically
important i thought that was important
i just make one point as you do it which
is
we must continue if we can in this
country to be a
financial tech a technological innovator
i mean look okay this business failed so
perhaps this is not the right time to
make this point but
there's a lot of innovation that's
taking place that are taking things that
banks
tended to do quite badly and making it
cheaper and more effective
for our constituents and i'd take the
example for instance of remittances
we've all got many constituents who
work very hard and send some of the
money home to families in other
countries
you know for years they've they've
placed high charges and poor service
and now technology blockchain and other
mechanisms and companies like
revolution monzo and all the rest of it
are making that much easier now that's a
great thing so
as we regulate better let's not lose the
ability of
technology and capital markets to
deliver
low-cost finance for for people who can
really benefit
yeah no i certainly support that and i
should declare that since i left the
british banks association i've also been
involved in financial technology firms
uh quite a few of them have been
invested and
they've been an actual legal director of
some um
my one question if you have described uh
green sale as a fintech firm
uh and one one thing i've learned from
my involvement in fintech is that it's
quite a
an appealing phrase and lots of people
describe confidence as fintech without
them really doing it without
really having any tech there and in
particular lots of people
uh use the words artificial intelligence
in a very sort of slap dash way
uh when they're actually there's nothing
that uh intelligent about it
uh it sounds technology i was just
wondering how much did you look at the
technology of uh green seal because
again they've been quality reports of
people lifting up the bonnet there had
no
proprietary platform itself uh there was
no there was nothing really that
sophisticated
about the technology i certainly
wouldn't pretend to be a
expert in this but it seemed to me what
green silver doing with partners like
oracle or
talia or textura in the past using
the information in a company's erp to
make sure
you could extend credit to
suppliers and indeed to employees faster
i think that does qualify for fintech
because the fin
is the access to the deep capital
markets and the tech
is using the erp
to make credit decisions better and
faster and i know that sounds all very
techy but
ultimately what it can be about is
trying to
you know make the cost of your mobile
phone lower making sure you can access
your pay on a daily basis rather than
waiting till the end of the month i
think these are quite powerful
changes so whether you want to call it
tech enabled
or fintech um you know that's a matter
of choice but
it's certainly using technology and
capital markets to to make people's
lives better
my last questions are about the um your
uh communication with the treasury you
obviously made
uh various explanations about exactly
what green seal did
uh there is as we said uh at the
beginning as you recognize serious
questions about
uh you know the potential for fraud
there and the business model not being
all that it
seemed and certainly you've seen a lot
of miners uh
uh um evidence about that um how much
did you
check uh what you're telling the
treasury was actually fully true and
that you are you
satisfied that you made all the right
inquiries to uh
to make sure that you as a former prime
minister were not passing on any false
information to the treasury
well that's a very good question the
briefing note that i
sent and you know many of the emails and
text messages were sending the same
briefing note to
different people that was drawn up in
consultation
with people at green sill and i asked
that it was very carefully checked and
that
all the information in it was right and
i believe that to be the case
and did you challenge any of the
information at all did you did they
provide you with the
pro forma i think it went through a
number of drafts
from memory i'd have to check that but
um that was the point i thought we had a
strong case i wanted to make sure we
didn't overstate anything
as i say i think you know we did make a
mistake in that
here was the ccff here was our proposal
to
enter into it and we took too many
iterations to get to something that was
really tailored to uk smes
um sterling currency only qualifying
companies we should have got there
faster and that is
you know i i was frustrated about that
and that's a you know regret
and that that did mean there was more
contact than there otherwise should have
been
and my last question you uh felicity
buck and asked you whether you regretted
this and you
you slightly started stepped out that's
in a direct direction
if you're in the same situation again
what exactly would you do differently
uh or would you do exactly the same
again well the first thing is if you
work for a company that goes into
administration you look back and think
could i have made a different choice um
you know i did do due diligence i did
ask people uh
and all the rest of it but you know it
is a
very depressing experience working with
for a company that goes into
administration and all the regret about
the people who've lost their jobs and
all the rest of it so that obviously is
something you'd you'd think about in
terms of the
contact with government ministers i've
said many times you know
ex-prime ministers are different and a
letter or an email
once is we were in special i mean what
i'm
saying to the committee is i think we
were in very special circumstances and
that explains
why i did um what i did um
but as i say there are lessons to learn
and and i'm sure your committee will
perhaps give me some other ones to learn
too can i just push you on that one
point
apart from sending a single letter or a
single email rather than the
volume of communication you had is there
anything else you would have done
differently throughout this episode well
also getting to a better answer to how
to amend the ccff faster
uh i think that is you know as i said
that was something we
could have done better also i think look
when the
company went into administration um
you know i waited quite a while before
making a 1700 word
statement or whatever it was i thought i
was not the right person to go out and
explain why the company got into
administration because i wasn't
running the company and i wasn't a
director um
but uh i think the expectation that
someone else would take that up and was
perhaps um
something i might do differently okay
thank you very much phil
thank you anthony i'm just gonna go back
to angela please
thank you very much uh mr cameron have
you got anything to say to those who've
lost money uh who invested in the funds
in
credit suisse um those small german
towns whose
townships have lost a lot of money
because of the uh what's happened at
greensville bank
do you have anything to say to them now
well i do have
obviously it's a great regret that this
company has
failed that it went into administration
um
uh you know and the people i feel most
sorry for the people
who work for green sill many of them at
the
hq in warrington who worked very hard
who believed deeply what the company was
doing and have
lost their jobs and of course if anyone
does
lose money through their investments
that's a matter of of regret
my understanding is with the funds is
it takes time for the assets to run off
because a lot of them are
receivables and if the underlying
company is
still paying their suppliers and
therefore paying back the funds
that money will be recovered so i think
it will take some time before we know
what exactly the consequences are but
obviously i'm extremely sorry for anyone
who's lost money or lost out or lost a
job
because of what has happened and mr
cameron what about the 5 000
workers who work at liberty steel whose
future is once more in
doubt and what about all of us taxpayers
who
subsidize the british business banks
loans uh which also uh are likely to be
irrecoverable as a result of this
collapse well obviously i'm very keen
for
britain to continue to have a steered
industry as prime minister
i got very involved in the issues about
port albert
and about scum thought and you know
we're a great
industrial nation i hope we can maintain
parts of our steel industry and for all
the
concerns i have about the concentration
on
gupta and gfg you know the idea of
a green steel industry where we melt
down more of our own scrap rather than
export it
and try to build a steel industry on
that basis is something that i think
has merit so i hope that um those
steel jobs uh can be maintained
i think look perhaps your committee can
help us get to the bottom of it
but it i think it wouldn't be fair to
say
well it's the failure of green sill that
is
putting gfg in jeopardy it's
a symbiotic relationship that obviously
went wrong between the two
um but uh i i'm you know let
all steel jobs that can be saved i hope
they can be
and lord mcpherson in his evidence to us
told us that it's
the phrase he used with typical
understatement because i know him well
too
is it is slightly disappointing that
officials time was wasted
uh when that was a valuable commodity
because of the wider crisis
did you give enough thought to what
treasurer was having to deal with
um before or during or after you were
generating your 56
messages well of course i did think
about
uh about this before calling the
treasury
and you know i read nick mcpherson's
evidence but also as i say would
draw your attention to the current
serving permanent secretary and deputy
permanent secretary who said that they
didn't feel under pressure they didn't
fit it was inappropriate
use of resources i think it is a genuine
question
about you know we know that the banks
have excellent access to the treasury in
quite right too but when a lot of
lending is carried out by
non-bank financial institutions and by
fintech firms i think it's important
that
the treasury the bank of england
understand how those work and how they
could be included in
in schemes so summing that up it's
really
no regrets then about your own personal
behavior i'm not saying that at all
um i think i've said very clearly that
you know ex-prime ministers
are different i've reflected on all
that's happened i think there were very
special circumstances in the
crisis the potential economic crisis
that followed kovid
but you know in future i accept that you
know ex-prime ministers in their
different position
um should restrict themselves to uh a
single letter to
make the points they might want to make
i mean hopefully there won't be any of
those but
it was a particular time
chair thank you very much
okay thanks very much david can i just
come back to one point which is annoying
away
a little bit um my intention is that
what somebody has paid or what incentive
financial incentive arrangement they may
be on
is not relevant when it comes to how
motivated
they are what the motivation is i think
most people would struggle with that
idea and i would accept that if these
are small amounts then you're probably
right but if they're very large amounts
then it's hard to argue
i think that they don't have wouldn't
have some bearing for certain most
people
as to how they would uh behave
under those circumstances so could i
just press you just a little bit harder
on this basic salary that you were with
uh on with green cell
i mean are we talking about something
say up to a million or over a million or
can you give us some kind of feel
because if it's a relatively small
amount then
then find it was a generous you know big
salary that you might earn
in someone in my position at a bank or
what have you
the reason for if you're being stubborn
and pursuing me i'm being stubborn
in my responses i do think it's
important for people to know there was a
economic interest absolutely both in pay
and cash and in shares but
the questions you're answering asking
and answering um
i don't think required to to the exact
um
figures but yes it was a you know a
generous salary
the generous salary could cover a lot of
possibilities couldn't it i mean can't
you give us something a little bit more
specific than that well i think you know
as i've said
if if i had gone to work for a
large bank um or such like as some of my
predecessors have done perhaps it would
have been
even more but i didn't want to go and
work for a large bank i was excited by
working
for a uk fintech firm but as i say in
anyone's
terms it was a generous salary
okay uh could i go to steve
please thank you chair and i refer to my
registered shareholding in glimp pay
which i do because we may
return to fintech mr cameron could i
just ask you to explain perhaps you
might like to refer to pharmacies why
you were so
keen on supply chain finance
i was keen on it for a very simple
reason maybe the way to do it is to go
back to 2012
when lecturing sill produced this scheme
in government
we were in a credit crunch and he
assembled the whole
team of uk corporates
who had agreed to pay their suppliers to
get their
suppliers paid early
and use supply chain finance effectively
extending
their credit terms because they can
borrow money very cheaply to all the
companies right down in their supply
chain
and it was this combination of using
capital markets and technology
to help small businesses get their bills
paid on time
that you know i saw as a not just a good
economic measure but a
socially useful measure and that was one
of the things that attracted me to
working for the business
so when mr green seal gave us evidence
he particularly talked about the
technology and machine learning when i
pressed him
what's your understanding about the
extent to which those
future prescriptions were certain
well if you take the nhs example so to
start with my understanding is the first
scheme was literally
instead of the pharmacy waiting you know
30 or 40 days for the nhs to cough up
the money
as soon as they had the invoice approved
they could get the money
from at that stage citibank so that was
classic receivables finance what changed
with the new scheme was that an
algorithm was being used to
help predict the prescription behavior
of each chemist
and so they could get the money in
advance of actually making the
prescriptions
now this was incredibly popular with
pharmacies
i mean a lot of them saw their cost of
capital plummet they saw um
cash flows to their business improve and
it was a very
successful scheme now i wouldn't overdo
the extent of machine learning and
artificial intelligence i mean it's
fairly predictable what a
if you think of the pharmacies in
is it high wycombe wickham yeah wickham
uh
you know you have a regular bunch of
customers with regular
prescriptions so it's quite easy to
predict um
but that was the use of some artificial
intelligence
or some algorithm to predict it but i
wouldn't overdo it but that is that is a
that is a future receivable and people
getting paid for it early
but how much was that market for wanted
better term worth
i don't have the figures and i don't
want to give a misleading thing i mean i
think
it was i mean i think we're talking
hundreds of millions
um because i think it was
um somewhere towards 20 of
nhs pharmacies that were using it
so for instance i can read here one
pharmacy said to us that we were
they were we're reducing their annual
charges from 7 000 pounds to 400 pounds
um so replacing you know old-fashioned
bank finance with
supply chain finance was meaningful for
these pharmacies and also
lex greens had explained probably saved
the nhs 100 million
pounds a year too i'm just referring to
a times article on the 27th of march
which suggests in a paragraph uh
connecting a meeting between lex
greensteal and richard douglas at the
department of health but in in that
paragraph it connects it with a figure
of 10 billion a year
i think the point i'm making here really
is that these are very large sums of
money involved when the public sector is
really getting stuck into supply chain
finance aren't they
they are big figures um and it does lead
to this whole question
why do you need an outside body to do it
why can't the nhs just pay faster which
i think some of the pac might go on to
when they talk to me later on but i i
think that is really worth answering
because the truth is
two things one is there's a lot of
bureaucracy in government and even with
the best win in the world sometimes the
early payment just simply doesn't happen
point one and point two i think nick
mcpherson in his evidence to you
was very clear about this he said
although the treasury is in favor of it
in
theory in practice early payment
means the treasury borrowing more money
and paying more interest on it
and so there is a cost and i think what
is
useful about using supply chain finance
even in the public sector is
of course if you're paying big suppliers
you know early they are paying for the
benefit of that rather than the taxpayer
so i
i think i think it'd be sad to sort of
rule out supply chain finance in the
public sector because i think it
can be very helpful for small businesses
like pharmacies and it can actually
save money for the government at the
same time so those of us who've been
involved with running businesses will
know that
it's it's common practice for a board to
just work out strategically what the
potential size of their business could
be
what the size of their customer base and
their market could be what was your
estimate what was the board's estimate
of the potential size of this supply
chain finance market within government
i don't have the figures for within
government i mean the point i'd make is
while there were lots of ideas in
government actually only one
the nhs pharmacy scheme actually
happened so
um i'm sure you could
ask brings in itself or a consultant to
give you an estimate i'm sure there are
lots of potential uses
but they have to be properly tested to
make sure the value for money and only
one
has actually happened in my view what
the overall size of the market could be
elsewhere
is you know as you know having run a
business
um working capital is an enorm working
capital globally is an enormous number
and if supply chain finance can provide
more working capital solutions there's a
very big addressable market
but there was a point in my briefing
pack i can't quite find it here but
there's
an account in the press of jeremy
haywood making introductions at the mod
for lex green sill
um suggesting that no stone should be
unturned
in terms of applying supply chain
finance to
the mod spending do you recognize that
as having taken place
i i don't know exactly look electric was
brought into government
by jeremy as i said in my statement to
help solve an important problem
and my understanding is lots of ideas
were looked at including the mod
the only one that actually came off
because i think it had such a good
working case was nhs pharmacies um
but i'm sure lots of other things were
looked at
um i think look jeremy i mean it's you
know
he's been attacked about some of these
things which i don't think is fair he's
not here to defend himself he was an
outstanding civil servant who
and he was wanted to bring
good people in to try and shake things
up and
deliver good public services and it's
important to put that on the record
so when the board was considering the
size of its market did it think that it
might end up applying supply chain
finance
to a billion 10 billion 100 billion of
government spending
um well the total amount of credit
extended by green silk in
last year was 140 billion that was
around the world taking in
whatever it is 150 countries in
government it was simply this nhs
pharmacy scheme and i can give you the
figure for that
i don't think i mean if you look at the
planned expansion of green sill
government provision wasn't a huge part
of it it was really winning
the big corporate clients all over the
world
um and and that was the biggest focus
for the business so what i'm driving at
here is by the time you're
using this method with government you're
using it with people's salaries you've
referred to the earned app the potential
size of this business
was hundreds and hundreds of billions of
pounds wasn't it
yes but remember that um the
fight if you take the 143 billion
dollars actually not pounds i mean that
is mostly funded
through intermediaries through the
credit suisse funds or through banks or
what have you so the financial capacity
um to deliver that particularly you know
something that is
low risk such as i mean i was a
passionate fan of the earned app
because you and i know there are lots of
people
in our public sector who access
payday lending or other forms of um
credit that cost them a lot of money um
and it'd be much better if they could
draw down their salary as they earn it
now of course if you
finance something like that um
you know the risks are very low because
the chance of
the nhs not paying its wages or
wages are very low so i i'm sorry i'm
giving you long answers but you can no
that's okay
um so to turn back to the covid
corporate finance
facility at the bank of england where
does that money come from when the bank
of england
issues it through that facility
um well the bank was acting on the
treasury's behalf
um i don't uh i mean i think it is
it's a it's a bank of england facility
that of course is there to
buy commercial paper and that is an
asset
and obviously if um those companies
continue to succeed
then the costs of that purchase will be
relatively low
well in the jargon it's it's financed by
reserved which by reserves which of
course means it's new money the covered
corporate finance facility as people
will find online
is new money coming into existence so it
wasn't the proposition that you were
making
i know you know that i've got a big
issue i i remember a conversation we had
about
money creation and your view yes but
let's not get into it now because i'm
running out of time but the point i'm
making is that when you were
arguing that green sill should use the
kovid corporate finance facility what
you were
effectively doing i think was arguing
that these securitize securitizations
should take advantage of the bank of
england's money creation isn't
isn't that right it is a very important
point green seal
at no point was asking for a loan or for
a bailout or for direct government
support that is not what was happening
what we do or what we did was
you know go to vodafone and say we'll
pay your suppliers early
you pay us in 60 or 90 days creator
bond based around that and if the
ccff had invested in bonds like that
that would have been money directly into
vodafone supply base and other british
companies supply bases
that's what these things are so they're
quite like
commercial paper now finally i feel i
must
with regret i must ask you a delicate
question because i feel if i don't ask
it
uh you know it will be asked elsewhere
were you at any point while you were
prime minister directly advised
by lex greenseal on the issue of supply
chain finance
and in the course of those conversations
at any stage
did he intimate that subsequently you
might end up working for greenself
well the answer to the first question is
he worked in downing street
he produced this one initiative which
was a combination of private sector
firms
signing up to do supply chain finance
and the nhs pharmacy scheme
that came to me from civil servants in
the proper way but i think it was
largely his work and we announced that
in october
2012 and as far as i was concerned that
was a successful scheme
i think i met him twice while i was in
danny street and i can absolutely
confirm
at no stage did he ever suggest that i
would go and
work with him or for him afterwards that
happened
after i left office and i think it's a
very important point thank you very much
great thank you steve um and will
shanara please
thank you mr cameron ed mubarak
i'm spending my afternoon with you
instead of my family
um and i'm lucky looking forward to
finishing and joining them
um we've so we've established that uh
mr sanjiv gupta was a marriage account
customer of greensville
um did you know how much money was being
loaned to
uh to mr gupta's metal empire gfg
alliance yes i don't have the
exact figures um as i say i wasn't
involved in the credit committee i
wasn't responsible for
spending credit so i wasn't responsible
for those decisions so i don't have a
question for you was did you know how
much
uh uh money was being loaned out
to gupta's metal empire no i don't have
that figure
you didn't know you didn't know i i knew
that
uh glg was a significant customer of
green sill i knew there was an issue
about client con
concentration i asked questions about
that i was reassured there was a plan to
deal with that
um and i think that's one of the
important reasons for this business not
succeeding
was the the financial times article in
2018
um spoke about the green city link and
described it as financial
alchemy um and yet you talked earlier
about doing the due diligence and it
seems like for someone who
you know ran our country um that perhaps
that due diligence
didn't serve you well ultimately i'm
going to move on to
another question we established in the
earlier
this uh comments and also the evidence
you've submitted that you lobbied the
chancellor
you also lobbied the then business
minister nadim zahawi
in june 2020. his department is
responsible for the british business
bank
um and my understanding is that
i understand that you are pressing for a
maximum
um loan to green hill um that could be
made under the treasury's correct you
know coronavirus large
business interruption loan scheme um
which was
increased ultimately from 50 million to
200 million
um and that was crucial
um and so so
would could we infer from what
ultimately happened
which is that eight times 50 million
pounds of loans
were a split and mr green sales company
were able to then uh give that loan to
gfg-link companies that that lobbying
effort that intensive lobbying effort
ultimately did pay off now i
wouldn't say that at all because the
green cell approached as i understand it
the british business bank to be
accredited
as a lender under these schemes
something which i had absolutely no
involvement with
and it was accredited as i think were
some other fintech firms not just
traditional
banks so that was a successful approach
when
green cell asked to be raised to the
higher level
that was ultimately rejected i think by
the british business bank and by the
treasury so
uh no i wouldn't agree with that um
formulation at all
okay so so did you can i just check
did you discuss the british business
back as a possible route to getting
funding
for green sale at your meeting with the
bank of england
i don't um believe i did as i said i
wasn't at all involved
until the moment of asking whether it
could go up to the higher level in the
british business bank accreditation
process my involvement with the
bank of england and the treasury was all
about the ccff because that was where
i think we were most enthusiastic about
having a
product that we thought was even better
than what they were suggesting and
fitted in quite well
and and did you have to you you're
pretty confident that you didn't discuss
the the other scheme the clb ils scheme
with the bank um what about did you have
any discussions with nigel boardman who
was a non-executive board member
just i must quantify something of course
um
richard sharp i did have a there's an
email except text exchange
in there richard sharp he wasn't at the
bank at that stage he was at the
treasury but just beat that point sorry
your question about nigel baldwin
yes did you have you did you have any
discussions
about the british business bank as a
possible route to getting going getting
funding
um with
the with nigel boardman did you have you
had any conversation with him in the
last couple of years
he was after all the exact board member
and also he's leading the inquiry
that uh the private current prime
minister has announced
i i don't i i haven't got any record of
conversations with him in the last two
years i can double check that
um i certainly haven't discussed any of
these issues with him but i'm going to
take part in his inquiry i think i'm
seeing him next week
um can you okay i hope you can um you'll
understand why i'm asking these
questions because there's there's a very
close
relationship between people in power or
people who have been in power like
yourself
and what we have as you've heard is the
specter of
a billion pounds as miners pointed out
and others have pointed out
the public money potentially you know
certainly at stake in three to five
billion lost to the taxpayer uh and
what we've heard today um you know
you're
you're always suggesting that
you're on i it frankly it feels like
you're not taking responsibility for
what's happened
i just want to come back to this point
about mr greenzill when he gave evidence
on tuesday
um he i asked the question about
the loans to the
to to mr gupta's companies um
can you just confirm for me um
the press reports that greensville
loaned a total of 400 million
in the clb ils
loans to gfg link companies and that
they were split across eight loans to
50 million i don't i don't have that
information as i say i wasn't involved
in any of those
lending decisions um so i don't have
that information and can't confirm that
right so you don't know you don't you
don't know
i mean it's i mean as a former prime
minister
um it seems like you either conveniently
turned a blind eye on things or you
didn't do the due diligence properly or
you didn't have proper oversight and
your reputation is in now
now in tata's mr cameron well i was an
advisor
to the company um and i thought i could
help the company with some
important tasks that included its
international expansion and winning
customers and working with partners
but i wasn't involved in lending
decisions
i wasn't a director i wasn't on the
credit or risk committees
and i think that you know that's a that
is a
perfectly good way of working with a
business
you're not responsible for the
day-to-day decisions you're not
responsible for the lending decisions
but nonetheless you're working with the
team
to try and help them um expand the
business
i talked about the due diligence that i
did before joining the company obviously
uh i greatly regret this company's gone
into administration and there are
lessons to learn from that which i'm
sure your committee are going to help us
all to learn
but the the issue here is that uh
mr grinstein's stills company
did find a way of circumventing the 50
million can
and ultimately 400 million pounds
worth of government taxpayer-funded
loans
were made available to gupta and
you you know very well the risks to
steel workers thousands of them and the
wider impact
on people and their taxpayer
should you not take some responsibility
for what's happened
because it seems like you know we're
gonna
wait well you're famously known as
teflon man you know you
you're very um you're a great survivor
you know and uh um uh
no one's taking responsibility and yet
taxpayers
are going to be being being uh gonna
already affected and they're gonna
continue to be affected by this well of
course
i take responsibility for my decision to
work with this business i take
responsibility for the
decisions i made with respect to
contacting the government for
all of those things um as i said to you
i hope that
these steel jobs survive um
you know i i'm not clear about i watch
paul miner's
evidence about this cost to the taxpayer
i really think
you know your committee will be able to
ask the treasury
for an accurate breakdown of what these
costs should be because
it might be because we haven't i think
seen those
um 400 with respect at the very least it
will be 400 million that they're very
conservative estimate
i think the difficulty is that um you
know it is a criticism of green sill
that it was overexposed to gupta and
lent too much money to gupta but if
you're saying that it's hard to say at
the same time
um that it wasn't trying to support
jobs in the steel industry um i think
perhaps the problem is there needed to
be more skepticism
from green sill about gupta and what was
happening
rather than believing that actually
uh the vision would be turned to reality
but we're getting a bit
beyond our brief but i think it's going
to be a while before we know
how this works out but i'm i i hope
we'll be able to
have as many steel jobs in this country
as we possibly can
i think i think what i'm trying to
establish is what
i'm what i'm trying to understand is
what the actual overall impact has been
um you've you've been given a very
hard time about the lobbying operation
and you know i would say that
from from ultimately from what happened
your association
with green seal and the lobbying
operation that took place did actually
in the end
benefits uh benefit uh the company
um that you were working with
right now i don't follow that argument
i'm afraid because
what we were asking for an extension of
the ccff to include supply chain finance
didn't happen the green cell's
accreditation
with the british business bank didn't
involve any
lobbying at all it was green seal going
through the accreditation process
and and like some other fintech
companies it was accredited as a
as a c bills lender so i
the argument you're making i i don't
follow because
actually ultimately um the
lobbying effort was unsuccessful the
treasury gave good reasons for that as i
said in my
evidence earlier and the treasury also
announced this new scheme the treasury
it was the treasury department not
biz not the british business bank which
was the cr
cr clb ls scheme
so anyway the point here is that
that this company ultimately did manage
to access
through these eight different 50 million
pound loans
access loans which were then provided to
companies associated with mr gupta which
has left the taxpayer
short i mean can i can i just can i just
say that
um having listened to the evidence
session in your response
i i think what people will be really
really deeply concerned and alarmed
about is that
how you allowed frankly someone who was
you know using you here either at best
at best he was using you
mr greenseal and at worst while frankly
exploiting your reputation
and bringing the office of the former
prime minister into distribute
and you kind of went along with it you
played along
and you should have been much much more
careful about the due diligence
and you turned a blind eye on things
that were blindingly obvious
well obviously i take a different view
which is that
i chose to work with green seal because
i thought it had a good core product in
extending credit and early payment to
small firms in our country
i believe that could be expanded with
huge benefit i believe that this could
have been
a uk fintech success story now very
sadly that hasn't happened to be the
case
but i did do due diligence i did look at
the board i did look at the
arrangements the company had in place um
but obviously i deeply regret
that you know this company has failed
and that has consequence
yeah and a huge consequences and i think
you know as
those of us who've worked with you it's
bitterly disappointing and frankly
you know this particular scandal is is a
huge
i mean it's reputation is so damaging to
our democracy because of the office you
held
but it's damaging in terms of real
consequences to real people's lives
well the point i would make is actually
in our country for all that i think we
can improve
uh transparency and rules around
lobbying and everything else is
people can see when businesses
meet with the government we know that in
lots of countries we didn't we don't
know that
and before i became prime minister no
one had any idea
who was meeting with government that is
transparent we have
a lobbying act so multi-client lobbyists
have to declare who they lobby on behalf
of
of course there's more we can do to
improve these systems
but ultimately a company i work with
made a suggestion to the government
the government turned it down and the
civil servants i think behaved
impeccably throughout and have explained
that what was done was perfectly
appropriate
and a sensible set of conversations were
gone into so i
i take a different view about how this
happened the
the sad thing is that the company itself
has now failed and jobs have been lost
and that has
real world consequences but i put it to
you mr cameron that what happened
and this was don't forget at a time when
um the government
was creating dealing with public
procurement contracts
you know we now know that there was a
separate vip lane for government
contracts
and your intense lobbying uh as a former
prime minister
made it very uncomfortable for ministers
and for officials
and in the end what i put it what i put
to you is that
yes the treasury um and others
said no to you politely that they found
another
route for you which was through the
british business bank
through the department and that allowed
and if you look at the chronology
of the announcements uh and that was
made that
where the the current virus large
business interruption loan was
introduced
it was done after that intensive
lobbying and i put it to you
that actually you were successful uh
ultimately in making sure that that
company
did benefit and that this stuff smacks
off
favoritism and power those in power like
yourself
with powerful connections and
relationships getting
access to decision makers and having the
access to the vip
lane the fast lane uh into what you want
uh and that is fundamentally damaging to
our democracy and it puts the civil
service the impartial nature of our
civil service
at you know in a
very difficult position and you should
have known better mr cameron
not because of the thing you've said
about lobbying you were the architect of
the lobbying act
you should have known better and frankly
it's bitterly disappointing
and frankly i have no pleasure in having
to sit in this meeting
with the former prime minister okay you
were in your own words you were the
future
once i have no pleasure in being in this
situation and
sitting in in front of you uh and for
the country to see
uh the former prime minister being used
in this way by frankly somebody
who was close to who's who was frankly
acting like a con artist
i just perhaps made one point on the
application to the british business bank
i mean i do believe that was a
separate application process in which
the treasury wasn't involved but it's
a very good question for your committee
to take up uh with the treasury about
whether that was a separate application
process i believe it was but that might
be one
outcome of this conversation for
announcing it i'm
i'm very grateful to your time i'm
simply saying it's deeply disappointing
and i hope
out of this episode and out of that
experience that you've had
that we can make sure that no prime
minister uh no prime minister
is ever caught up in a scandal of this
of this nature
uh because it's bad for our democracy
it's bad for our impartial
civil service you will never you will
never be disassociated from the office
of prime minister
around the world and even though you're
not from my party
i have huge respect for the position of
prime minister and a former prime
minister and it's bitterly disappointing
what's happened
this whole episode is appalling for our
country and our democracy
right um david unless do you have
anything further to say
i think that brings us to the end of
this uh
session um it's been a very difficult um
session uh i think uh for you david in a
number of
different ways and undoubtedly the
committee has been robust and in some
cases extremely robust
with you however we are a courteous
committee we do very much appreciate you
having appeared
uh before us uh today and i know you
have found it difficult in part but
you did stand up and be counted and come
and sit in front of this committee and
take
uh our questions and for that uh we are
grateful
and that concludes this session
order order okay
thanks
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has